[music]
>> Yeah, we're good.
Okay, folks.
We're at capacity.
Let's kick off. I don't want you waiting
here for 25 more minutes before we some
arbitrary deadline.
So,
welcome.
My name's Matt,
I'm a teacher, and I suppose now I teach
AI.
Um
We have a link up here, if you've not
already been to this, which is has the
exercises for the um stuff we're going
to do today.
This is going to be around 2 hours, so
we might just sort of kick off 2 hours
from now. Is that all right, Mike?
Yeah, perfect.
Um and
the theory behind this talk, or at least
the thesis under which I've been
operating for the last kind of 6 months
or so, is that
we all think that AI is a new paradigm,
right? AI is obviously changing a lot of
things. You guys are obviously
interested in this, and that's why
you've come to this talk.
And
I feel that
when we talk about AI being a new
paradigm, we forget that actually
software engineering fundamentals, the
stuff that's really crucial to working
with humans, also works super well with
AI.
And this is what my keynote is on
tomorrow, really. I'm going to sort of
be fleshing that out a lot more.
And in this workshop, I'm hopefully
going to be able to direct your
attention to those things, and
uh hopefully show you
that I'm right. But we'll see.
Um can I get a quick heads-up first? How
many of you guys um are coding have ever
coded with AI? Raise your hand if you've
ever coded with AI. Perfect. Okay. Uh
keep your hand raised.
Uh
let's all uh share those armpits with
the world. Um
how many of you code every day with AI?
Cool. Okay. Uh right, keep your hand
raised if you've ever been frustrated
with AI.
Okay, very good.
You can put your hands down.
Thank you for that show of obedience. I
really appreciate that. And we are also
being live-streamed to the Gilgood room
as well. I've not
uh
Did we send someone up to the Gilgood
room to just check they're okay?
Don't know.
But I see you,
and there is a way that you can
participate, which is we have the um a
Q&A. We're going to be doing kind of
have a sort of hatred of Q&As cuz
they're not very democratic. They're
mostly the sort of
um most talkative people get to um
get to participate and share. And so,
we're going to be going through this um
Q&A here. So, why do we have to wait
till 3:45? The room is packed, the doors
are closed. 100% agree.
And so, if you want to uh ask a
question, we're going to be I would like
you to pile into this async, and then we
can vote on each other's questions, and
hopefully get the best questions
surfaced so the for the entire room to
enjoy.
So, I want to talk about first the kind
of weird constraints that LLMs have.
And
those weird constraints are sort of what
we have to base a lot of our work
around.
Now,
there's a guy called Dex Hardy who runs
a company called Human Layer, and he
came up with this idea, which is that
when you're working with LLMs, they have
a smart zone
and a dumb zone.
When you're first kind of like
working with an LLM, and it's like
you've just started a new conversation,
you start from nothing, that's when the
LLM is going to do its best work.
Because in that situation, the attention
relationships are the least strained.
Every time you add a token to an LLM,
it's kind of like you're adding a team
to a football league. You think of the
number of matches that get added every
time you add a team to a football
league, it just goes
it scales quadratically. And that's
because you have attention relationships
going from essentially each token to the
other that are positional and the sort
of meaning of the individual token.
And so, this means that by around sort
of 40% or around I would say around 100K
is kind of my new marker for this. Cuz
it doesn't matter whether you're using 1
million
uh context window or 200K,
it's always going to be about this.
It starts to just get dumber.
So, as you continually keep adding stuff
to the same context window, it just gets
dumber and dumber until it's making kind
of stupid decisions. Raise your hand if
that feels familiar to you.
Yeah, cool.
So, this means that we kind of want to
size our tasks in a way that sticks
within the smart zone.
Right? We don't want the AI to bite off
more than it can chew. This goes back to
old advice like Martin Fowler in
refactoring. Uh like uh the pragmatic
programmer talks about this. Don't bite
off more than you can chew. Keep your
tasks small so that you as a developer,
a human developer, don't freak out and
don't start acting and going into the
dumb zone.
But
how do you tackle big tasks? How do you
take a large task like I don't know,
cloning a company or something, or just
doing something crazy,
and how do you break it into small tasks
so they all fit into the dumb zone?
One way, of course, you could do is I
mean, kind of what the AI companies
maybe want you to do, or the natural way
of doing it is just keep going and going
and going, you end up in the dumb zone,
charging you tons of tokens per request.
You then compact back down.
We'll talk about compacting properly in
a minute. And you keep going, keep
going, keep going, compact back down,
keep going, keep going, keep going.
And I think that's doesn't really work
very well because the more sediment I
we'll talk about that in a minute.
So, the theory here is then, and this is
what I was doing for a while,
is I would use these kind of
um multi-phase plans.
Where I would say, "Okay, we have this
sort of number four thing here, this
large large task. Let's break it down
into small sections so that we can then
kind of chunk it up and do each little
bit of work in the smart zone." Raise
your hand if you've ever used a
multi-phase plan before.
Yeah, really common practice, right?
This is kind of how we've been doing it.
Certainly, this is how I was doing it up
until December last year, really.
And any developer worth their salt will
look at this and go, "This is a loop."
Right? This is a loop. We've just got
phase one, phase two, phase three, phase
four. Why don't we just have phase N?
Right?
Phase N. Where we essentially just say,
"Okay,
we have, let's say, a plan operating in
the background, and then we just loop
over the top of it, and we go through
until it's complete."
And this is where um
Raise your hand if you've heard of Ralph
Wiggum as a software practice.
Okay, cool. Raise your hand if you've
not heard of Ralph Wiggum as a software
practice, actually. That's more like it.
Okay. So, there's this idea called Ralph
Wiggum, uh which is kind of um
sort of based on this,
which is essentially
all you need to do is sort of specify
the end of the journey,
where you just say, "Okay, we create a
PRD, a product requirements document, to
say, 'Whoa, okay, let's describe where
we're going.'" And then we just say to
the AI, "Just make a small change. Make
a small change that gets us closer and
closer to that."
And
Ralph works okay, but I prefer a little
bit more structure.
So, that's kind of where we got to in
terms of thinking about the smart zone,
and that's
kind of where I want you to first start
thinking about here.
Another weird constraint of LLMs is LLMs
are kind of like the guy from Memento,
right? They just continually forget.
They could just keep resetting back to
the base state.
Let me pull up this diagram.
I sort of I
I I really should use slides, but I just
prefer just like randomly scrolling
around a
uh infinite uh TL draw canvas. Thank
you, Steve.
Um
So, let's say another concept I want you
to have is that every session with an
LLM kind of goes through the same
stages.
You have, first of all, the system
prompt here. This gray box here is
essentially the stuff that's always in
your context. You want this to be as
small as possible. Cuz if you have a ton
of stuff in here, if you have 250K
tokens, like I have seen people put in
there, then that you're just going to go
straight into the dumb zone without even
being able to do anything.
So, you want this to be tiny.
>> [snorts]
>> You then go into a kind of exploratory
phase. This blue sort of where the
coding agent is going out and exploring
the code base.
Then you go into implementation.
And then you go into testing.
And sort of making sure that it works,
running your feedback loops and things
like this.
Raise your hand if that feels familiar
based on what you've done. Yeah. Sort of
the like the the main cornerstones of
any session.
And when you clear the context, you go
right back to the system prompt.
Oof, you go right back there. So, you
delete everything that's come before.
And
raise your hand if you've heard of
compacting, as well.
Yeah, okay. There are some people who've
not heard of compacting. So, let's just
quickly show what that means.
For instance,
I've just been having a little chat with
my LLM.
Uh
I want to make sure we sort of, you
know, just cover the basics so we're all
sort of on the same wavelength here.
I've just been having a chat with my
LLM.
I've been talking about a thing that I
want to build. How's the font size?
Should I bump it up?
Folks in the back?
Bump. Bump.
Bump. Bump. Bump. Oh.
I'm using Claude Code for this session,
but you don't need to use Claude Code.
Uh
in fact, it's often nice not to use
Claude Code.
Um
so, I've been having a chat with the
LLM, just sort of planning out what I'm
going to do next. It's asking me a bunch
of questions, and I can
I highly recommend you do this.
There's this tiny little status line
here that tells me how many tokens I'm
using, the exact number of tokens I'm
using. Um I have a article on my website
AI Hero if you want to copy this. This
is
Oh, wow, that is that shakes, doesn't
it? Um
this is essential information on every
coding session cuz you need to know
exactly how many tokens you're using so
that you know how close you are to the
dumb zone.
Absolutely essential.
And so let's watch it.
So I've got two options. I can either
clear
wrong and go back to nothing or I can
compact.
And when I compact then it's going to
squeeze all of that conversation, which
admittedly isn't very much, into a much
smaller space.
And this in diagram terms kind of looks
like this.
Where you take all of the information
from the session and you essentially
create a history out of it, a written
record of what happened.
And devs love compacting for some
reason, but I hate it.
I much prefer my AI to behave like
uh the guy from Memento because this
state
is always the same. Always the same
every time you do it. You clear and you
go back to the beginning. And so if
you're able to do that and you're able
to optimize for that then you're in a
great spot.
So that's kind of the two things I want
you to think about with LLMs, the two
constraints that we're working with.
They have a smart zone and a dumb zone
and they're like the guy from Memento.
So let's take a look at the first
exercise.
And I'm while I'm doing this, the way I
want this to work is I'm going to sort
of show you how um I'm going to be sort
of walking through it up here and I want
you folks to be kind of like tapping
away and doing things as well. So that
was just a little lecture bit. Let's now
actually get and do some coding.
For anyone who arrived late or anyone in
the Gilgud room uh go to this link
this link up here
to see the exercises and clone the repo.
You absolutely do not have to, you can
just watch me do it if you fancy it.
But let's go there myself and let's see
what exercises await us.
So essentially I've built a um this is
from my course.
This is a uh a course management
platform essentially, a kind of CMS for
instructors, for students, and this is
what we're going to be building a
feature in. So I'm going to take you
from essentially the idea for the
feature all the way up to building a PRD
for the feature, all the way up to
implementing the feature.
And hopefully you can take inspiration
from this process and use it in your own
work.
So
uh let's kick off. So
we're going to start by using a a skill
which is very close to my heart.
It's the grill me skill.
And this grill me skill is wonderfully
small wonderfully tiny and it helps
prevent one of I think the main issues
when you're working with an AI, which is
misalignments.
The uh
the sort of silent idea that I'm talking
against here, that I'm arguing against,
is the specs to code movement. Has
anyone heard of the specs to code
movement? Raise your hand. It's not
really a movement I suppose, it's just
sort of people saying specs to code.
Um
what it is is people say, "Okay, you can
write a program or you want to build an
app the best way to build that app is to
take some specifications
so to write some sort of like document
and then turn that document into code."
So they just turn it into code. How do
you do that? You pass it to AI. If
there's something wrong with the
resulting code, you don't look at the
code, you look back at the specs. You
change the specs and you sort of just
keep going like this. This is kind of
like vibe coding by another name where
you're essentially ignoring the code.
You don't need to worry about the code.
You just sort of keep editing the specs
and eventually you just keep going. And
I tried this. I really tried it. And it
sucks. It doesn't work.
Because you need to keep a handle on the
code. You need to understand what's in
it. You need to shape it because the
code is your battleground. And so
this is again is where we're going.
Let's let's get some exercises.
So
what I'd like you to do is go to this
page, the the grill me skill.
And inside the repo here
we have a slack message
from our pal. Uh where is it? It's in
the root of the repo and it's under
bur bur bur bur
Oh, where is it?
Mhm mhm client brief.md.
It's a slack message from Sarah Chen.
For some reason the Claude always
chooses Sarah Chen as the name. I don't
know why.
Um it's saying that in cadence, our um
course platform, our retention numbers
are not great. Students sign up to a few
lessons then they drop off. I'd love to
add some gamification to the platform.
And so when you're presented with an
idea like this, you need to find some
way of turning it into reality. Let's
say Sarah Chen is your client, you're on
a tight budget, you need to get this
done fast. How do you go and do it?
Um
raise your hand if you would um
enter plan mode when you're doing this.
Anyone a big user of plan mode? Yep.
Um let's actually shout out quickly any
other ideas about what you would do with
this or any Raise your hand if you
what what would be your first port of
call?
Yep. Ask for more info.
Sorry? Ask for more
info to verify what is the purpose and
where our current standing is. Yes,
exactly. Let's imagine that Sarah Chen's
gone on holiday, you have no idea,
right? Uh she's just posted this thing,
you need to action it before you go.
Well, my first port of call is I go for
this particular skill. I'm going to
clear my context.
I'm going to
uh get rid of
you, you don't need to be there.
And I'm going to say
um I'm going to invoke a skill
which is the grill me skill. Let's
quickly check.
Raise your hands if you don't know what
this is.
Cool.
Oh, sorry sorry. Let me be more
specific. Raise your hands if you don't
know what I'm doing here when I
uh do a forward slash and then type
something.
Anyone Everyone kind of understand what
that is?
I'm invoking a skill. I'm invoking the
grill me skill.
And what I'm going to do is I'm going to
say grill me and I'm going to pass in
the client brief.
So now
the LLM really has only a couple of
things here. It just has the skill and
it has the description of what I want to
do.
And this is virtually how I start every
piece of work with AI.
And while it's exploring the code base
I'm just going to show you what the
grill me skill does.
So this is inside the repo so you can
check it out.
It's extremely short.
"Interview me relentlessly about every
aspect of this plan until we reach a
shared understanding. Walk down each
branch of the decision tree resolving
dependencies one by one. For each
question provide your recommended
answer.
Ask the questions one at a time uh blah
blah blah."
What this does and what I noticed when I
was working with AI, especially in plan
mode actually
is it would
really eagerly try to produce a plan for
me.
It would say, "Okay, I think I've got
enough. I'm just going to poof plan
plan."
And what I found was that
I was really trying to find the words
for this, for for what I wanted instead
of that.
And Frederick P. Brooks in The Design of
Design, he has a great quote uh talking
about the design concept.
When you're working on something new
with someone
when you're uh all trying to build
something together
then there's this shared idea that's
shared between all participants and that
is the design concept. And that's what I
realized I needed with Claude. I needed
I needed to reach a shared
understanding. need an asset, I didn't
need a plan, I needed to be on the same
wavelength as the AI, as my agent. And
this is an extremely effective way of
doing it. So hopefully
Here we go. Nice. It has done its
exploration first of all.
It's invoked a sub agent which spent
97 93.7k tokens
on Opus.
Um
and it's asked me the first question.
Cool.
We can see that even though the sub
agent burned a a ton of tokens I haven't
actually um
uh increased my token usage that much.
Raise your hand if you don't know what
sub agents are. It's important question.
Everyone kind of clear what sub agents
are? Okay, I'll give a brief definition.
Which is that this this sub agents thing
here, this explore sub agent it has
essentially gone and called another LLM
which has an isolated context window.
And then that LLM has reported a summary
back. So a sub agent is kind of like a
delegation. You're delegating a task to
a sub agent. It goes eagerly does all
the thing, explores a ton of stuff and
then just drip feeds the important stuff
back up to the orchestrator agent.
To the parent agent. So okay. So
hopefully you guys have seen the same
thing. It's done an explore.
And we now have our first question.
Points economy. What actions earn points
and how much? Ooh, okay.
At this point you can ask it by the way
questions to um deepen your
understanding of the repo. I obviously
know this repo really well cuz I wrote
it, but you might not um
know what's going on.
So let's say my recommendation, keep it
simple, two point sources to start.
What's so nice about this is that not
only does it give us a question that
kind of aligns us here, we get a
recommendation too. And often what I'll
find is the AI's recommendations are
really good.
And so I'll just say
skip video watch events, they're noisy
and gameable. I agree.
Sarah's asked we'll keep the lessons in
the bread and butter.
Yeah.
Looks good, pal.
>> [snorts]
>> Now what I usually do is I usually
dictate to the AI. I'm usually actually
chatting to the AI instead of uh typing
here, but uh this is a relatively new
laptop and I couldn't get my dictation
software working on it um because
Windows is crap. Um
So, should points be retroactive? There
are existing lesson progress records
with completion at timestamps. This is a
really nasty question, right? Should we
actually go back and backfill all of the
lesson progress events? This is a kind
of question that you need to be aligned
on if you're going to fulfill the
feature properly. This is not something
I considered and Sarah Chen certainly
didn't consider.
Do I want it to be retroactive? Hmm.
Let's actually do a vote inside here.
Should we go back and backfill all the
records? Raise your hand if you think we
should backfill all the records.
Raise your hand if you think we
shouldn't backfill all the records.
There are a lot of fence-sitters in the
room. I'm going to say
you know, this is the kind of discussion
you're sort of having with the AI.
You're getting further aligned. Yes, I'm
just going to go with his recommendation
cuz I'm lazy.
Notice too how I'm able to keep in the
loop here with AI. I'm not you know,
it's it's pinging me these questions
pretty quickly.
I'm not having to go off and check
Twitter or something.
Levels. What's the progression curve?
Yeah, that looks about right. For
instance, yes, okay.
So hopefully you should be able to go
and um
kind of work through this with the AI.
>> [clears throat]
>> And essentially
try to reach an alignment. And this
grill me skill, this can last a long
time. This can I've had it ask me 40
questions. I've had it ask me 80
questions. I've had some people that
asks 100 questions too. Literally you're
sat there for an hour chatting to the
AI.
And what you end up with is essentially
this conversation history
that works really nicely and works
really nicely as an asset of the design
concept that you're creating.
This can also function like this. You
can
have a meeting with someone who's a
maybe a domain expert. Maybe I have a
meeting with Sarah. I feed that meeting
transcript into
I don't know, Gemini meetings or
whatever you guys are using. You take
that, you feed it into a grilling
session and you grill through the
assumptions that you didn't have.
So this ends up being a really nice kind
of
um
a really nice way of just taking inputs
from the world and then just turning and
validating them.
So okay.
Let's see. I really want to get to the
end of this, but I also don't want to
just like be sat here talking to the AI
in front of you for uh
a thousand days. So I'm just going to
say yes.
Let's see what happens.
So I'll tell you what, um while you guys
sort of have a little fiddle with this
locally, let's start a little Q&A
session now.
And
let's see. How's this going to work?
Can we keep the door closed or turn up
the microphone? It's quite noisy.
Uh
let's see. Mike, can we uh
door closed. Oh it has been closed. Mark
has answered. Beautiful.
So what I'd like you to do
is there any air con? Yeah, there is
some air con, I think.
There is some air con.
You guys aren't being lit here. I'm
being fro I'm being fried alive here.
Uh so what I'd like you to do is go on
to the Slido, which you can join here.
Have a if if you're not taking the
exercise, go on to the Slido, have a
little fiddle and vote on some good
questions. I'm just going to chat to the
AI for a second
uh until we reach a stopping point. So
do streaks earn points?
Um
streaks are standalone.
Let's see what else it comes up with.
Where does gamification UI live?
Let's have it in the dashboard.
I'm just going to scan these and blast
through them basically.
So how are we doing with our Slido?
Okay.
Have I tried Spec Kit, Open Spec or
Taskmaster instead of the Grill Me
skill? Do I find them more verbose or a
structured alternative? This is a great
question. So there are a ton of
different frameworks out there that
allow you to um sort of build up this
planning process for you. I personally
believe you at at this stage, when
there's no clear winner, when there's no
kind of like one true way and when
things are changing all the time, you
need to own as much of your planning
stack as you possibly can.
What I've noticed and a lot of my
students
is
they tend to overuse a certain stack.
They get into trouble
and they because they don't own the
stack and they don't have observability
over the whole thing, they just go
this isn't working. This sucks. Whereas
if
um
if you have control over the whole
thing, then at least you know how to fix
it or potentially know how to fix it.
So I'm even though I'm sort of giving
you uh a stack basically, I believe in
inversion of control and you should be
in control of the stack.
So bur bur bur.
Can I press zero, please?
Sorry?
Sorry, that was a lot of sort of
mumbling. Can I
Thank you.
I'm so sorry.
>> [laughter]
>> What you didn't want to give Claude good
feedback? What is what is wrong with
you?
Uh okay, cool.
Uh many of the questions asked by the
Grill Me skill are not necessarily
appropriate for a developer, rather a
PO. In larger teams, who should use it?
Yeah.
Um
Raise your hand if um
you've ever done pair programming.
Anyone ever done pair programming?
Right. I keep Put your hands down and
raise your hand again if you've ever
done a pair programming session with an
AI.
Right.
How did it go? Was it good? You enjoy
it? I think pair programming sessions
with AI is a great idea because you've
got a third person in the room who will
relentlessly quiz you and ask you
questions. It should If you don't know
the answer, it should be you, the domain
expert and the AI in the same room. If
you're have a question about
implementation, it should be you, a
fellow developer and the AI in the same
room, you know. You can be sort of
working through these questions in your
team. And I think actually
we're going to look at implementation in
a bit and we're going to see how you can
make implementation so much faster.
And but I think the really crucial
decisions, the ones you need humans for
you actually need a lot of humans and it
doesn't really matter how many humans
are in there. You can actually throw a
bunch like a kind of like mob
programming with AI essentially.
Uh what's my favorite meta prompting
tool? I think I kind of answered that.
Uh there's no air con. Let's just live
with it. Uh
how do I use the conversation as an
asset after the Grill Me session? Well,
we're going to get there.
Um okay, so I really want to
I want to speed this up sort of
artificially.
Just what
I This is the thing. So someone just
said okay, Ralph loop this. But this is
crucial because I can't loop over this,
right? I can't um
I think of there is being two types of
tasks in the AI age.
Where you have human in the loop tasks,
where a human needs to sit there and do
it.
Which is this.
We are the human in the loop, with
multiple humans in the loop. And there
are AFK tasks. There are tasks where the
human can be away from the keyboard and
it doesn't matter. Implementation, as
we'll see, can be turned into an AFK
task. But planning, this alignment
phase, has to be human in the loop. Has
to be.
So I've got to do it, unfortunately.
Um
I don't know.
Uh
give me a long list of all your
recommendations.
I'm running a workshop right now.
So I artificially
need you to
pull more weight.
So let's see what it does.
Uh let's answer a couple more questions
while it's doing its thing.
What is my opinion on PMs or other
non-dev roles vibe coding task?
Hmm.
Um I'm going to return to this later, I
think. I'm going to leave this
unanswered.
A bit of mystery.
I notice I'm not using the ask user
questions UI for Grill Me. Why? Um
there's a specific uh
UI that you can bring up in Claude Code.
I'll answer this just quickly.
Uh ask me a question using the ask user
question tool.
>> [snorts]
>> And this UI um is just sort of broken in
Claude and I really hate it.
You notice I'm using Claude, but I don't
like Claude very much. Like you you
really are free with this method to
choose any um system you like. And this
is what the UI looks like.
It's very pleasing when you first
encounter it, but then you realize it is
actually broken in a ton of different
ways.
All right, what did it come back with?
Oh blimey.
Oh no.
So
while this is doing its thing, let me do
some teaching in the meantime.
The plan here is that we take our Grill
Me skill
and we need to essentially find some way
of turning it into
a destination.
We need to go down to the
uh
We essentially need to
we're figuring out the shape of this.
That's what we're doing. We're figuring
out the shape of the tasks during the
grilling session.
And in order to
turn it into a bunch of actionable
actions for the AI
we essentially need to figure out the
destination. We need to know where we're
going. We need to know the shape of this
entire thing.
So I think of there is being two
essential documents that we need.
We need a document that
documents the destination.
Oh no.
It's so not bright enough. There we go.
Still not brighter. There we go.
We need something to document the
destination.
And we need something to document the
journey.
In other words, we need something a
document that's going to
figure out what this even looks like in
all of its user stories and figure out a
definition of done
and then we need to figure out what the
split looks like.
So, that's where we're going to go to
next.
So, once we finish with the grilling
session,
yeah, it looks great. Fantastic. I love
it. It answered
it answered 22 of its own questions.
There you go. That's quite
representative of what a grilling
session looks like.
So, at this point now,
I have used 25k tokens and all of that
or loads of that stuff is gold. I want
to keep that around. I've I've got 25k
great tokens there.
And what I want to do is kind of
summarize it in some kind of destination
documents.
So, this is um the next exercise
where we're going to
uh we're going to write a product
requirements document.
And the the product requirements
documents or the PRD
is essentially
that's its function. It's the
destination documents. And it's sort of
doesn't matter what shape it is. I've
got a shape that I prefer and I quite
like.
But, you can just choose your own shape
or whatever your company uses.
And all we're really doing is I'm not
too worried about that.
All we're really doing is summarizing
the design concept that we have so far.
And
the So, let let's try this.
So, I'm going to initiate this. I'm
going to say
zoom all the way to the bottom.
All I'm going to do is just say write a
PRD.
And we can take a look at that skill
now.
Write a PRD.
So, this skill
it does a few things.
It first asks the user for a long
detailed description of the problem. You
can use write a PRD without grilling
first, but I just like to grill first
and then write the PRD afterwards.
Then you can um get it to install the
repo which we've kind of already done.
Then we get it to
interview the user relentlessly so we
have a kind of grilling session again
and then we start um putting together a
PRD template. So, this is available in
the repo if you want to check it out.
And essentially this is what it looks
like. We've got some problem statements,
the problem the user is facing, the
solution to the problem and a set of
user stories. And these user stories
sort of define what this is. You know,
as
you you guys have probably seen things
like this if you've been a developer at
all. Um you know, there are cucumber is
a language you can use to write these in
or we just sort of
um
uh write them ourselves essentially.
Then we have a list of implementation
decisions that were made and list of
crucially testing decisions, too.
So,
I'm going to run this. Okay. And so,
it's finished its thing.
Ah!
Windows, let me close the thing. Thank
you.
I don't know why I bought a Windows
laptop. I think I just
I like the challenge. Um
>> [clears throat]
>> So, the first thing that it's going to
give me
are a set of proposed modules it wants
to modify.
Now, there's a deep reason why I'm
thinking about this. So, this is
at this stage
we have an idea, we have sort of specked
out the idea, we've reached a sort of
understanding of what we're trying to do
and then we need to start thinking about
the code
because at this point we need to
this is not specs to code. This is not
where we're ignoring the code. We
actually keep the code in mind
throughout the whole process.
And
the way I like to do this is I like to
just sort of think about a set of
proposed modules to modify. We're going
to return to this this idea of
continually designing your system and
keeping your system in mind.
So, it's it's saying recommend tests for
the gamification service is the only
deep module with meaningful logic. These
modules look right. Yeah.
Looks good.
And it's going to hang out a PRD.
Now, for ease of setup
I've got it so that it creates a set of
issues locally.
So, it's just going to create
essentially a PRD inside this issues
directory.
But, the way I usually do it
and you can check this out yourself is
you can go to my um essentially what I
consider my work repo
which is GitHub um dot com forward slash
Matt Pocock forward slash course video
manager up here.
And in here, this is essentially a app
that I create um that I use all the time
to record my videos and things like
this. I think I've recorded like
I pulled out the stats. I think I've
recorded like a thousand videos in here
or something nuts.
Um and you can see here that it's got
744 closed issues.
And this is essentially all of the uh
PRDs and all of the implementation
issues that I've put into here. So, this
is how I usually like to do it.
>> [clears throat]
>> So, that's what I'm doing with the There
we go. Yeah, I'm just going to say yes
and uh
and get that issue out.
Let's see. It is inside here.
So, we've got the problem statements.
People signing up for courses.
Uh the solution, the user stories, uh 18
user stories looks nice, some
implementation decisions, level
thresholds, etc. This is enough
information. We've kind of clarified
where we're going and what we're doing.
So, that's what we do. We essentially
have a grilling session and we've
created an asset out of it. Now, raise
your hand.
Should I be reviewing this document?
Raise your hand if you think I should be
reviewing the documents.
Yeah, I don't I don't look at these.
I don't look at these.
The reason I don't look at these is
because what am I testing at this point?
What am I Like when I read it,
what am I testing? What am I What are
the failure modes I'm trying to test
for?
I know that LLMs are great at
summarization
cuz they are. They're really good at
summarization.
I have reached the same wavelength as
the LLM, right? Using the grill me
skill, we have a shared design concept.
So, if I have a shared design concept,
all I'm doing
is I'm just essentially checking the
LLM's ability to summarize.
So, I don't tend to read these.
Let's have Let's have a Q&A cuz I can
feel you guys are itching for it. And I
think we might have like
I don't know, just a 5-minute comfort
break just to uh rest my voice and so
you can catch up with the exercises for
a minute if that's all right. So, let's
have a little Q&A sesh.
Uh
If I don't like Claude Code, which one
do I actually like? Um
uh
Have you ever heard the phrase um
uh democracy is the worst way to run a
country apart from all the other ways?
That's how I feel about Claude Code.
Uh we've answered that one.
Uh
What's your thoughts on developers
needing to very deeply understand
TypeScript now that fix the TS make no
mistakes exist? I don't understand the
phrasing of this,
but I think I understand meaning,
which is that
I believe that code is very important
and this is kind of going to feed
through the whole session and that bad
code bases make bad agents. If you have
a garbage code base, you're going to get
garbage out of the agent that's working
in that code base. We'll talk more about
that in a bit.
And so, I think understanding these
tools very deeply, understanding code
deeply is going to make you a much much
better developer and get more out of AI.
Uh and that answers that question, too.
Sweet.
Uh
Get out of there. There you are.
Now that we have 1 million tokens
available, do we ever actually want to
take advantage of that?
I've noticed that the dumb zone has
become less dumb lately. Okay, great
question. This goes back to our kind of
initial idea on the dumb zone.
Uh
I am I recorded my Claude Code course
using a 200k context window and on the
day that I launched the course they
announced the 1 million context window.
My take on this is that what Claude Code
did is they essentially just did this.
Wee!
They shipped a lot more dumb zone to you
essentially. Now, this is good for tasks
where you want to retrieve things from a
large context window. If you want to
pass five copies of War and Peace or
something to it and you want to find out
all the things that uh
uh I can't remember a character from War
and Peace. Uh
Why did I start with that?
It's good for retrieval.
It's less good for coding.
So, I consider that it is about 100k at
the moment is the smart zone. The smart
zone will get bigger and that will be a
really nice improvement.
So, folks, we're going to take it like a
5-minute comfort break if that's all
right just for my voice and to maybe you
can have a little move around or
something or grab a drink. I can just
notice some sleepy eyes and I want to
make sure that we're awake for the next
bit if that's all right. So, we'll take
5 minutes and I will see you back here
then. All right?
So, we have
our PRD
which I'm not going to read, our kind of
destination document. Let's quickly scan
for any good questions before we zoom
ahead.
And
Rediscovering the role of software
engineering today's world, top three
disciplines you recommend.
Um
Taekwondo is good, I've heard. I've no
I've no idea how to answer this
question. Um
thank you for asking it though. Um Top
three disciplines I recommend.
I mean
Sorry? Plumbing. Plumbing is a good one.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. I don't know if that's
a discipline. I the plumbers I've hired
are not usually very disciplined.
Um
Right.
So, okay. We now have our destination,
okay? Um
Perfect.
So, how do we actually get to our
destination? How do we We have a sort of
vague PRD? How do we split it so that we
don't put things into the dumb zone?
In other words, we have our number four,
how do we split it into this kind of
multi-phase plan? Well, probably what
you would do at this point is you would
say, "Okay, Claude, give me a
multi-phase plan that gets me to this
destination, right?" That sort of makes
sense. This is what we've been doing
before.
But I have um
a sort of better way of doing it now,
which is that
I like
creating a Kanban board out of this.
Raise your hand if you don't know what a
Kanban board is.
Mm, cool. Okay. A Kanban board is
essentially just a set of tickets that
you put on the wall that have blocking
relationships to each other. So, we're
going to see what it kind of looks like
here. This is how we've worked um
as developers for a long time, really
since Agile came around. And what it
does, we can see it here,
it has proposed that we split this setup
into
um five different tasks here.
We have the first one, which is the
schema and the gamification service.
Yeah, well, that looks pretty good. This
is blocked by nothing.
And we can even see here that it's a
it's given it a type of AFK, too. You
remember I talked about human in the
loop and AFK earlier? This is an AFK
task. This is something we can just pass
off to an agent to do its thing.
Streak tracking, okay, that looks good.
Uh
then wire points and streaks into
lessons quiz completion. This is blocked
by one and two.
Retroactive backfill. This is blocked
only by one.
And then this one here is blocked by all
of the tasks. Cool.
Hmm.
Now, I consider this you could say, "Why
don't we just make this sort of
generation of the issues, why don't we
just hand that over to the AI? Why do I
need to be involved here, right?" Cuz
it's given us quite a good selection of
tools here. Why do I need to review this
and sort of
figure out what's next?
Now, my take here is that this is really
cheap to do, like very quick to do once
I've done the PR, and I can immediately
see some issues here.
There's a really, really important
technique when you're kind of figuring
out what the shape of this journey
should look like.
And
it sort of comes to this very classic
idea, uh which comes from the Pragmatic
Programmer called traceable bullets or
vertical slices.
And traceable bullets really transformed
the way I think about actually
getting AI to pick its own tasks.
Systems have layers, right?
There are layers in your system.
These might be different deployable
units. You might have a database that
lives somewhere. You might have an API
that lives maybe close to the database
but in a separate bit. You might have a
front end that lives somewhere totally
different like a CDN.
Or within these deployable units, you
might have different layers within
those. In for instance, the code base
that we're working in, we have a ton of
different services. Service. We have a
quiz service, a team service, a user
service, coupon service, core service.
And these services have dependencies on
each other. So, they're kind of like
individual layers.
Well,
what I noticed is that AI loves to code
horizontally.
So, it loves to code layer by layer.
So, in other words, in phase one, it
will do all of the database stuff, all
of the schema, all of the you know, all
the stuff related to that unit. Then it
will go into phase two and do all of the
API stuff. Then it will add the front
end on top of that.
Does Can anyone tell me what's wrong
with that picture? Why is that not a
good thing to do? Raise your hand if you
have an answer.
Yeah.
>> have that whole feedback loop.
Exactly. You don't get feedback on your
work until you've
really started or completed phase three.
So,
what you really need to do is you you're
not until you get to phase three, you're
not actually testing that all the layers
work together.
You haven't got an integrated system
that you can test against.
And so,
instead you need to think about vertical
layers. You need to think about thin
slices of functionality that cross all
of the layers that you need to.
And this is a much better way to work,
much better way for the AI to work, too,
because it means at the end of phase one
or during phase one it can get feedback
on its entire flow.
So, what this means to me
is inside the PRD to issues skill up
here,
I have got break a PRD into
independently grabbable issues using
vertical slices traceable bullets
written as local markdown files.
[snorts]
We first locate the PRD.
Uh again, explore the code base if this
is a fresh session. We draft vertical
slices.
So, we break the PRD into traceable
issues. A traceable bullet, by the way,
is uh
essentially when you're like an
anti-aircraft gunner. It's quite a
violent idea, actually. Uh
and you're looking up in the sky and
it's night. If you're just shooting
normal bullets, you have no idea what
you're firing at, right? You could just
be you know, you you see the plane but
you don't see where your bullets are
going.
Traceable bullets is they attach a tiny
bit of phosphorescence or phosphor or
something to make it glow as it goes.
So, this means that every sixth bullet
or something you actually see a line in
the sky. So, you have feedback on where
you're aiming. So, this is what this is
the idea here is that we increase our
level of feedback and we get near
instant feedback on what we're building.
Cuz without that the AI is kind of
coding blind until it reaches the later
phases.
We got some vertical slice rules. We
quiz the user.
And then we create the issue files. So,
what I see here
is that even though
I've I've told it to do vertical slices,
it's proposing to
create the gamification service
first on its own. That's just one slice
there. And that to me feels like a
horizontal slice. What I want to see in
the first vertical slice especially is I
want to see the schema changes or some
schema changes. I want to see some new
service being created and I want a
minimal representation of that on the
front end. So, I want it to go through
the vertical slices, not just the
horizontal. Does that make sense?
Okay. So, I'm going to give the AI
a rollicking.
Uh bad boy. No, I'm not.
I'm not going to waste tokens just being
just naming. Um
So, the first slice is too horizontal.
I'll just start with that and see if it
picks it up.
Does that make sense as a concept?
And I think having that um
what I really like about going back to
those old books is that we're really
trying to in this day and age like get
uh
verbalize best software practices in
English.
And these books, 20-year-old books, have
already done that. And it's an absolute
gold mine if you want to throw that into
prompts. But even with that, it's not
going to um not going to do a perfect
job each time.
So,
award points for lesson completion
visible on dashboard. Yes, that's a
beautiful vertical slice because it's
definitely a big chunk of stuff. It's
doing a lot of stories there, but we're
going to see something visible at the
end and the AI will then just be able to
add to that. You see why that's
preferable to the first one. Cool.
Uh looks great.
So, we're getting closer now. Anyone
following at home as well, you know, not
at home but you get the idea.
Um will hopefully see the same thing,
too, and start developing the same
instincts.
Let's open up for questions just while
I'm still creating these GitHub issues.
Uh ba ba ba ba Oh, not GitHub issues. Uh
local issues.
When will I stop using Windows? Never.
What is your Okay, we'll get to that
later.
How does AI um decide when to stop
grilling? Cuz AI can ask incessantly,
can we have a smarter way to decide the
stop point? Yeah, it does tend to really
um
those grilling sessions can be super
intense. And the thing about these
skills is you can tune them if you want
to. If you feel like the AI is just
absolutely hammering you, hammering you,
hammering you, then you can just
tell it to just pull back a little bit
or get it to do, you know, stop points
and that kind of thing. So, if that's a
failure mode that you run into a lot,
then you just, you know, change the
skill.
Uh do I still use uh be extremely
concise, sacrifice grammar for the sake
of concision? Um there was a tip that I
gave folks um
5 months ago, which is that
to basically increase the readability of
your plans. So, when you're using plan
mode,
then you can put it in your Claude.md
and you can say, "Okay, yeah, approve
that."
Let's open up Claude.md.
Uh do I have a Claude.md? Maybe I don't.
I I really don't use Claude.md very
much. I'm just going to put a dummy
inside here.
Um when
No.
When talking to me,
uh sacrifice grammar for the sake of
concision.
And this um prompt was uh really useful
to me when I was reading the plans
because it meant that the plans would
come out and they would be very concise,
really nice, easy to read, often very
concise. But I've
since dropped this idea in preference to
a grilling session because what I
noticed with it just I didn't want to
read the plans. I wanted to get on the
same wavelength as the LLM. I wanted it
to ask aggressive questions to me. And
when I stopped reading the plans, I
stopped needing them to be concise.
So, I think of the plans really in the
destination document as uh the end
state. And I don't need that end state
to be concise.
Hopefully that answers your question.
Uh
What do I think will be the outcome of
the Mexican standoff of future roles of
PMs and other roles converging? Uh I've
no idea. I'm not a pundit. I've no idea.
Uh okay.
So, we should
uh after a couple of approvals,
uh end up with a set of issues.
Now,
these issues that we're creating,
they're designed to be independently
grabbable,
which means that this Kanban board ends
up looking kind of like this.
Where you have
essentially a set of tickets with a
whole load of independent relationships.
So, this one needs to be done before
this one. This one needs to be done
before this one.
And this one, let's say we got another
one over here.
This one needs to be done before this
one.
This means that you can start to
parallelize.
You can start to get agents working at
the same time on these tasks. Because
yeah, this one needs to be done first.
And then
these two
can be grabbed at the same time by
independent agents.
Raise your hand if you've done any kind
of parallelization work with agents.
Okay, cool. So, this allows you
um to turn those plans into to optimally
kind of like into a directed acyclic
graphs essentially, where you just are
able to um
essentially have three phases here.
Where you have
phase one.
Uh let me grab move that.
Uh
above this line here,
you do this one.
Then phase two, you do the two below it.
And then phase three, you do this third
one and add it onto that.
And when you think about there could be
This could This is a relatively simple
plan, but you could have many different
plans operating all at once. It means
that you can do really nice
parallelization. And we'll talk more
about that in a bit. But that's why I
prefer a Kanban board set up like this
to a sequential plan. Because a
sequential plan can really only be
picked up by one agent.
So, this
Where did it go? Over here.
Yeah, this plan here
This is really only one loop, right?
Only one agent can work on these because
we have numbered phases and they're not
parallelizable. Does that make sense?
Cool.
So, we've got our issues. Ah, come on.
Stop asking me for I know it's creating
them on GitHub. I really don't want
that.
Oh, no.
You fool.
Create them in issues instead.
No.
That's not precise enough.
Uh you fool.
Create them in local markdown files
instead, referencing the local version.
Sorry about this.
So, once we get to this point,
we [clears throat] have a bunch of
issues locally
that we can start um looping over and
implementing. And it's at this point
that the human leaves the loop.
So, so far
Let me pull up a a proper overview of
this kind of flow that we're exploring
here.
So far
we have taken an idea.
I'll zoom this in a bit for the folks at
the back.
And we've grilled ourselves about the
idea.
We can skip over research and prototype,
but we turn that into a PRD, into a
destination document.
We then turn that PRD into a Kanban
board. And all of those steps
are human reviewed.
And now
the implementation stage, we step back.
And we let an agent um work through that
Kanban board or multiple agents work
through the Kanban board.
Now, what this means is that yeah, we
spent a lot of time planning here, but
it means that we've queued up a lot of
work for the agent. We can think of this
as kind of like the day shift and the
night shift. This is the day shift for
the human, right? Planning everything,
getting all the all the stuff ready. And
then once we kick it over to the night
shift, the AI can just work AFK. But
what does that look like?
Well,
so I'm just going to Oh, yeah. Just
allow it. It's perfect.
So, this looks like
if we head to the next exercise,
which is
uh in fact, the last exercise here,
running your AFK agent.
Now,
I've called this uh Ralph really cuz it
is a it is essentially a Ralph loop.
And this prompt here, I want to walk
through this really closely.
The first thing it's doing here is we're
essentially going to run Claude
and we're going to basically try to
encourage it to work um
completely AFK.
I'll show you what the sort of script
for this looks like in a minute.
But you say, "Okay, local issue files
from issues are provided at the start of
context."
The way we do that is if you look inside
once.sh here inside the repo,
we have
uh it's essentially just a bash script,
where we grab all of the issues,
um [clears throat] which are inside
markdown files, and we cat them into a
local variable. So, that issues variable
contains all of the issues that are in
our entire backlog.
Then we grab the last five commits. I'll
explain why in a minute.
And then we grab the prompt and we just
run Claude code with permission mode
accept edits.
And then just essentially just pass it
all of the information.
This is what the implementer looks like.
So, that's what a very very simple
version of this sort of loop looks like.
And of course, this is not a loop. This
is just running it once.
The loop
is in the AFK version up here,
which is uh a fair bit more complicated.
And the crucial part here is we're
running it in Docker sandbox as well.
So, I I don't want you to install Docker
on your laptops because we're just going
to be like, "You need to download a
special image and we're going to tank
the conference Wi-Fi if we do that." So,
I'm I am going to demo this to you, but
you um
won't need to run this yourself, but
I'll talk through this in a minute. But
essentially, this once loop here,
and ba ba ba ba boom.
We're just essentially running one
version of the thing that we're going to
loop again and again and again. So, this
is kind of like the human in the loop
version. And this is essential. Running
this again and again is essential
because you're going to see what the
agent does and see how it ends up
working. And any tuning that you need to
add to the prompt, then you can do that.
Let's go to the prompt.
Um
So, local issue files are being passed
in.
You're going to work on the AFK issues
only. That makes sense.
If all AFK tasks are complete, output
this no more tasks thing.
And then the next thing, pick the next
task.
So,
what we're doing here is we're
essentially running a backlog or
curating a backlog that our AFK agent is
going to pick up. That's the purpose of
all of these um setups in the beginning.
In this uh
all the way to this Kanban board here,
we're just essentially creating a
backlog of tasks for the night shift to
pick up.
And the night shift, this sort of Ralph
prompt here, it's got its own idea about
what a good task looks like to next pick
up.
I'm I did talk about parallelization. I
will show you this later, but this is
essentially a sequential loop here.
We're just going to run one coding agent
at a time. This is a good way to just
sort of um get your feet wet
essentially.
So, it's prioritizing critical bug
fixes, development infrastructure, then
trace bullets,
then polishing quick wins and refactors.
And then we just have a very simple kind
of instruction on how to complete the
task.
So, we explore the repo.
Use TDD to complete the task. I'll get
to that later.
And
we then run some feedback loops. So,
let's let's just try this and let's just
see what happens.
So, good. It's created the issue files.
We should be good to go. I'm going to
cancel out of this.
I'll clear and I'm going to run
uh
Where is it? Ralph
once.sh. And you can feel free if you're
following along to do the same thing.
So, we can see it's just running Claude
inside here
with the prompt and with all of the
issues that have been passed in.
And while it's doing its thing,
you probably have some questions about
this setup and about the decisions that
I've made to essentially
delegate all of my coding to AI, right?
So, let's let's do a quick Q&A while
it's getting its feet under it.
Uh okay. Ba ba ba ba ba.
I'm going to just
remove those.
How do you retain negative decisions,
things that you decided against, and
rationales when persisting the results
from the grill me session? Uh great
question.
There's a very simple answer, which is
the in the PRD uh write a PRD section,
there is a stuff at the bottom, a
section of the things that are out of
scope. So, the things we're not going to
tackle in this PRD, which is very
important for giving a definition of
done.
Feel free to ping on the Slido if you've
got any more questions.
Uh what's my front end workflow? Okay,
it's a great question. I'm going to I'm
going to answer that in a minute, I
think.
How to deal with agents producing more
code that we can review? How to properly
parallelize and use multiple agents
separate way. Okay, that's That's two
questions there.
Um
Raise your hand
if you feel like you're doing more code
review now than you used to.
Yeah, definitely.
Um
I don't think there's a way to avoid
this.
If we delegate all of our coding to
agents,
you notice that the implementation here
is really the only AFK bit. We then also
need to QA the work and code review the
work, right?
And if we are
running these loops where it's
essentially going to implement four
issues in one,
it's hard to pair that with the dictum
that you should keep pull requests small
and self-contained, right? Like small
self-contained pull requests means
you're needing to do fewer loops or
shorter loops or something.
Or maybe you do like a big stack of PRs,
but that seems horrible as well. That's
still just more separated code to
review. I don't honestly know what the
answer to this yet.
I think we just need to be ready to be
doing more code review, essentially.
Which is not fun. That's not fun thing
to say. That's not like I don't know. I
don't feel good saying that, but I do
think it's probably the
the way things are going.
It's a great question.
Uh
Can we grab a couple of questions from
the room as well? Let's not We won't do
the mic, but uh raise your hand if
you've got a question for me
immediately.
Yeah.
So, the approach is very linear from an
idea to uh QA code review. Of course,
the real world is a lot more messy. So,
you have all these ideas that are in
parallel and
nobody has the full picture. And
uh while you're working on something,
something else comes in as
a bug. Yeah. How do you deal with the
messiness? How do you tighten that
feedback loop? Great question. So, the
question was
if this all looks great if you're a solo
developer, but actually how do you
implement this in a team? How do you
gather team feedback on this?
And my answer to that is that if you
have an idea up there
and
essentially the sort of journey from the
idea to the destination
is something you need to figure out with
the team, right? So, all of this stuff
up here, this is kind of like team
stuff, you know what I mean? This So, if
you have an idea and you do a grilling
session on it and you have a question
that you don't know how to answer, then
you need to loop in your team as we
described before. Then you might need to
go, "Okay, like we just need to build a
prototype of this. We need to actually
hash this out. We need something that
the domain experts can fiddle with."
Or okay, we might need to integrate a a
third-party library into this. We might
need to do some research. We might need
to actually kind of like um
ping this back and forth and find a
third-party service that we can get the
most out of. We might need to go back
with the information that we gathered
there to the idea phase. So, all the way
up to the sort of PRD in the journey,
that's something you need to involve
your team with. That's something where
these assets are going to be shared over
and you're going to have requests for
comments on them and that that loop is
going to just keep grinding and grinding
until you figure out where you're going.
Once you figure out where you're going,
then you can start doing the Kanban
board implementation. But this is
essentially super arguable and the
you'll be bouncing back and forth
between the phases. Does that make
sense? Yeah.
Would you not need a
PRD for your prototype?
Say again, sorry. Would you not want to
have a PRD for your prototype? The
question was, do you want to go through
this whole session just to sort of
create a prototype? You don't need a PRD
for your prototype as well. Let's just
quickly talk about prototypes for a
second.
Um there was a question about how do you
make this work for front end?
Like how do you cuz front end is like
really sensitive to human eyes. You need
human eyes looking at the front end all
the time to make sure that it looks
good.
AI doesn't really have any eyes. It can
look at code,
but it front end is multimodal.
And so my experiences with trying to
plug AI into um let's say agent browser
or Playwright MCP to give it
You can give it tools to allow it to
look through a front end and sort of
look at images, but in my experience the
um it's not very good at that yet and it
can't create a nice front end in a
mature code base. It can sort of spit
one out. But what it can do is you say,
"Okay, uh I want some ideas on how uh
this front end might look. Give me three
prototypes um that I can click between
in a throwaway uh
throwaway route that I can decide which
one looks best." And you take the asset
of that prototype and you then feed it
back into the grilling session or you
get feedback on it, blah blah blah blah
blah.
Answer your question kind of thing?
The prototype is just, you know, it's
messy. It's supposed to give you
feedback earlier on the process.
So, that's a great way of working with
front end code, great way of looking at
software architecture in general. Let's
go one more question here. Yes.
>> [clears throat]
>> In your system, how do you integrate
respecting an architecture and design
with API contracts and fitting with your
larger system?
Uh security constraints, all kinds of
constraints like that.
Yeah.
There's a lot in that question. The
question was, how do you conform with
existing architecture? How do you do um
how do you make it conform to the code
standards
like of your code base or Yeah, the
architecture design APIs, Yeah. security
rules that constrain your design. Yeah.
I'm going to answer that in a bit.
That's okay.
So, hopefully we have started to get
some stuff cook cooking. Uh it's just
pinging on the explore phase here.
Hmm, tempted to just start running it
AFK.
Maybe I will, maybe I won't.
Um
What it's essentially doing is it's
exploring the repo. It's going to then
start implementing based on what we
wanted.
Let's actually have one more question
just while it's running. Yeah.
Why not AI
QA everything
Yeah.
So, the question was, why do you not get
AI to QA?
AI to QA.
I just got uh jargon overload for a
second. Um why do you not get AI to uh
test its own code? Now, of course, you
absolutely can. And I think while it's
doing while it's cooking here,
okay, it's got a clear picture of the
code base. It's assessing the issues.
It's doing issue 02 as the next task.
I'm again going to show you that in a
bit, I think. The sort of uh cuz you
definitely should do an automated review
step as part of implementation.
So, you have your implementation, you
should then, because tokens are pretty
cheap and AI is actually really good at
reviewing stuff, you should get it to
review its own code before you then QA
it.
I found that that catches a ton of
different bugs
and
the way that works is I will just do a
little diagram is if you have, let's
say, an implementation that sort of like
used up a bunch of tokens in the smart
zone,
if you get it to sort of try to
do its reviewing, it's going to be doing
the reviewing in the dumb zone.
And so, the reviewer will be dumber than
the thing that actually implemented it.
If we imagine this is the
uh let's be consistent. That's the
review.
That's the implementation.
Whereas if you clear the context,
then
you're essentially going to be able to
just review in the smart zone, which is
where you want to be.
Let's see how our implementation is
doing.
Okay, good. It's generating a migration.
That looks pretty nice.
We're getting some code spitting out.
And
while I'm sort of like Aha, here we go.
TDD.
Let's talk about TDD and then I think
we'll have a little another little
break.
TDD I found is absolutely essential for
getting the most out of agents. Uh raise
your hand if uh you know what TDD is.
Cool. Okay. TDD is test-driven
development. What it's essentially doing
is it's doing a something called red
green refactor. And if you look in the
code base, you'll be able to find a um a
skill which really describes how to do
red green refactor and teaches the AI
how to do it.
So, what it's doing is it's writing a
failing test first. So, it's saying,
"Okay, I've broken down the idea of what
I'm doing and I'm just going to write a
single test that fails and then I need
to make the implementation pass."
I have found that
first of all, this adds tests to the
code base and these this tends to add
good tests to the code base. And so,
we've got this kind of gamification
service.
It looks like it's
using some existing stuff to create a
test database. Test fails because the
module doesn't exist yet. Okay, we've
confirmed red. And then it goes and
hopefully runs it and it passes.
I found that uh raise your hand if
you've ever had AI write bad tests.
Yeah.
It tends to try to cheat at the tests
because it's sort of doing it in layers.
It will do the entire implementation and
then it will do the entire test layer
just below it.
Uh
I'm just going to say yes, you're
allowed to use NPX V test.
And using this technique, it generally
is a lot harder to
cheat because it's
sort of instrumenting the code before
it's then writing the code. So, I find
that TDD is so so good for places where
you can pull it off. In fact, it's so
good that I sort of warped my whole uh
technique around getting TDD to work
better.
I can see some dripping eyes. It is so
hot in here.
You can't imagine how hot it is up here.
Let's take another 5-minute comfort
break. Let's come back at quarter to, I
think. Have a nice generous one.
And we'll be back in about 6 7 minutes
and I'll talk about how
uh I think about modules, think about
constructing a code base to make this
possible.
I've just been sort of fiddling with the
AI here and we have ended up with some
with a commit.
So, we have something to test. Issue
number two is complete. Here's what was
done.
This is kind of what it looks like when
a Ralph loop completes is you end up
with a little summary.
Um and we have now something we can QA.
Because we did the feedback loops
because we did the trace bullets because
we were uh said, "Okay, give us
something reviewable at the end of
this." We can immediately go and QA it.
Now, there's nothing uh less exciting
than watching someone else QA something.
But, hopefully we can have a little
play.
Let's just check that it uh works at
all.
In fact, before I go there, I just want
to sort of work through what just
happened.
Which is we see that it's created some
stuff on the dashboard.
And it then ran the feedback loops. So,
it then ran the tests and the types.
Now, TDD is obviously really important.
And it's really important because these
feedback loops are essential to AI,
essential to get AI to produce anything
reasonable.
Because without this, AI is totally
coding blind, right?
You have to have to um
If if your code base doesn't have
feedback loops, you're never ever ever
going to get decent AI decent output out
of AI. And often what you'll find is
that the quality of your feedback loops
influences how good your AI can code,
essentially. That is the ceiling. So, if
you're getting bad outputs from your AI,
you often need to increase the quality
of your feedback loops.
We'll talk about how to do that in a
minute.
Now, so it ran NPM run test, NPM run
type check. It got one type error, and
it needed to fix it with a nice bit of
TypeScript magic. Very good. Yeah, type
of level threshold number. Okay.
Uh you see why I stopped teaching
TypeScript cuz just AI knows everything
now.
Um
So, and it ran the tests, and it passed,
and it's looking good. So, we now end up
with 284 tests in this repo. Pretty
good.
I I do find uh front end really hard to
test here. We're essentially just
testing the service. So, we've created a
gamification service, if we look up
here.
And then we have a test for that
service. You can see that the service
and the test itself.
Now, if I was doing code review here, I
would then go to I would first go to
review the tests, make sure the tests
were testing reasonable things,
and then go and kind of review the code
itself just to make sure that it's it's
not doing anything too crazy, right?
The essential thing is I need to
actually um look at the dashboard.
I'm going to log in as a student.
Oh, if it'll let me. Maybe it won't let
me.
Come on, son. There we go.
Let's log in as Emma Wilson.
Head into courses.
Uh let's say I've got an introduction to
TypeScript.
Continue learning.
Uh yes, I completed this lesson.
And something went wrong. I imagine it's
because I don't have
Uh SQLite error. I don't have the right
table. So, I need a table point events.
Point events is a strange table name.
I'm not sure quite what it was thinking
there.
Uh let's suspend. Let's run uh NPM DB
migrate.
Push, I think.
I can't remember which one it was.
But, you kind of get the idea, right? I
I'm not going to subject you to uh
watching me do QA because it's so dull.
Um but at this point, I would
essentially go back in. I would um
Let me open the project back up.
Uh and I would
This This is a crucial moment, um and
it's so important to um
QA it manually here because QA Oh, dear,
oh dear. What's going wrong? There we
go.
QA is how I then um impose my
uh
opinions back onto the code base, how I
impose my taste.
What you'll often find is that um there
are teams out there who are trying to
automate everything, like every part of
this process. And they will tend to
uh if you try to like automate the sort
of creation of the idea, automate
uh the QA, automate the research,
automate the prototype, you end up with
uh apps that I feel just lack taste
and are bad.
Maybe they just don't work, or they they
don't even work as intended, or there's
just no
You need a human touch when you're
building this stuff because without
that, you just end up with slop.
And we are not producing slop here.
We're trying to produce high-quality
stuff, and so that's what the QA is for.
Mhm.
So, I'm going to do two things in this
final section.
Which is I'm going to first tell you how
to
There's probably a question in your mind
here, which is let's say I have a code
base that I'm working on.
And it's a bad code base. It's a code
base that's like really complicated, uh
that AI just never does good work in,
and maybe actually most humans that go
into that code base don't do good work.
How what How do I improve that code
base?
And the second thing is I'll show you my
setup for parallelization.
So, let's go with um
bad code first.
Now,
where is it? Where's the diagram? Here
it is.
In his book, um The Philosophy of
Software Design,
John Ousterhout talks about
the ideal type of module.
And let's imagine that you have a code
base that looks like this. Each of these
uh blocks here are individual files.
And these files
export things from them. You know, they
have um things that you pull from the
files that you then use in other things.
And so, you might have these weird
dependencies where this file over here
might rely on this file, or might rely
on that file, for instance.
Now, if these files are small and they
don't kind of ex- like
export many things, then John Ousterhout
would call these shallow modules,
essentially. Where they're not very um
They kind of look like uh this, if I No,
actually no. I can't can't make a good
diagram of it.
They're essentially lots and lots of
small chunks. Now, this is hard for the
AI to navigate
cuz it doesn't really understand the
dependencies between everything. It
can't work out where everything is. You
know, it has to sort of manually track
through the entire graph and go, "Okay,
this relies on this. This one relies on
this one. This one relies on this one."
And it's then also hard to test this, as
well, because where do you draw your
test boundaries here?
Do you test each module individually?
Like just literally draw a test boundary
No, don't do that.
Around this one?
And then maybe another test boundary
around the next one, and then the next
one?
Or should you sort of do big groups of
it? Should you say, "Okay, we're going
to test all of these related modules
together, and just sort of, you know,
hope and pray that they work."
Now,
>> [sighs]
>> this means that if I think that bad
tests mostly look like that, where the
AI essentially tries to sort of wrap
every tiny function in its own test
boundary, and then just sort of test
that those individually work. But, what
that does is it means that when, let's
say, this module over here calls those
two,
so it depends on both of these, then
this module might miss order the
functions, or there might be sort of
stuff inside that poor module that's
worth testing on its own. And if you
then wrap this in a test boundary, what
do you do? Do you mock the other two
modules? How does that work?
So, actually figuring out how to um
build a code base that is easy to test
is essential here. Because if our code
base is easy to test, then our code our
feedback loops are going to be better,
and the AI is going to do better work in
our code base. Does that make sense?
So, what does a good code base looks
like look like?
Well, not like that.
It looks like this.
Where you have
what John Ousterhout calls deep modules.
Modules that have a little interface on
there that expose a small, simple
interface that have a lot of
functionality inside them.
Now,
what this means is that these are easy
to test cuz you just Let's say that
there's a dependency between this one
and this one.
My arrow working? Yeah, there we go.
Then,
what you do is you just wrap a big test
boundary around that one module, around
this one up here,
and you're going to catch a lot of good
stuff.
Because there's lots of functionality
that you're testing, and really the
caller, the person calling the module,
is going to have a simple interface to
work from. So, it's not not too tricky.
That makes sense? Deep modules versus
shallow modules. This is good.
This shallow version is bad. And what I
find is that unaided
um or if you don't
uh
if you don't watch AI carefully, it's
going to produce a code base that looks
like this.
So, you need to be really, really
careful when you're directing it.
And that's why, too,
is that if we look inside the PRD,
uh where is the PRD gone? It's inside
the issues. It's inside the gamification
system.
Uh not found. Of course, it's not. Here
it is.
Then I have
uh inside here
data model the modules.
So, it's specifically saying, "Okay,
this gamification service is a new deep
module, which we're going to test
around.
It's going to have this particular
interface.
And it's going to have um Okay, we're
modifying the progress service, too.
We're modifying the lesson route. We're
modifying the dashboard route, etc. So,
it's I'm being really specific about the
modules that I'm editing, and I'm making
sure that I keep that module map in my
mind at all times, throughout the
planning, and then throughout the
implementation. Does that make sense?
Very, very useful.
It's useful for one other reason, too.
Not only does it make your app more
testable,
but you get to do a little mental trick.
And I'm going to refill my water while
you wait for what that is.
Uh let me
Let me get a question from you guys. So,
raise your hands if you feel like
Uh if you feel like you're working
harder than ever before with AI.
Yeah.
Uh raise your hands if you feel like you
know your code base less well
than you used to.
Yeah.
This is a real thing. Um
because we're moving fast, because we're
delegating more things, we end up losing
a sense of our code base. And if we lose
the sense of our code base, we're not
going to be able to improve it, and
we're essentially delegating the shape
of it to AI.
I [snorts] don't think that's good. But
then how do we
how do we make it so that we can move
fast while still keeping enough space in
our brains?
I think that this is a way to do it.
Because what you're doing here is not
only are you thinking about creating big
shapes in your code base, big services.
What I think you should do is
design the interface for these modules,
but then delegate the implementation.
In other words, these modules can become
like gray boxes, where you just need to
know the shape of them, you need to know
what they do, and it's sort of how they
behave, but you can delegate the
implementation of those modules. I found
this is really nice. I don't necessarily
need to code review everything inside
that module. I don't necessarily need to
know everything of what it's doing. I
just need to know that it behaves a
certain way under certain conditions,
and that it does its thing. So, it's
kind of like
okay, I've got a big overview of my code
base, and I understand kind of the
shapes inside it, understand what the
interfaces all do, but
I can delegate what's inside.
I found that has been a really nice way
to retain my sense of the code base
while preserving my sanity.
Make sense?
And so, you might ask, how do I take a
code base
that looks like this
and then turn it into a code base that
looks like this? How do I deepen the
modules?
Well, we have Hopefully, it's in here.
Pretty sure it is. We have a skill.
And that skill is called improve code
base architecture.
Nice and direct.
Uh let's run it.
What this skill is going to do is it's
essentially just going to do it a scan
of our code base and looking for what's
available here. And feel free to run
this yourself if you're um
uh
running the exercises.
And it's exploring the architecture,
exploring um
essentially how to work within this code
base, and it's going to attempt to
uh find places to deepen the modules.
Pretty simple. One really cool um thing
that it found here is part of my uh part
of my course video manager app is a
video editor. A video editor built in
the browser, which is really hardcore.
Uh it's a decent bit of engineering. And
I wanted a way that I could wrap the
entire front end all the way to the back
end in like a single big module, so that
I could test the fact that I press
something on the front end and it goes
all the way to the back end. And so, I
found a way essentially by using a kind
of discriminated union between the two
types here by sort of I was able to use
this uh skill to essentially have a huge
great big module that just tested from
the outside, it was testable from the
outside, this video editor
infrastructure. And it meant that AI
could see the entire flow, could act on
the entire flow, and test on the entire
flow. And honestly, it was just night
and day in terms of the uh ability of AI
to actually make changes, cuz AI working
on a video editor is pretty brutal if
you don't give it good tests. So, that
is
Honestly, I
If you take one thing away from today,
just try running this skill
on your repo and see what happens.
Let's go to Slido. Let's ask a
check a couple of questions as well this
is running.
So, let's see. Have you tried Claude's
auto mode with Claude enable auto mode?
That way you can avoid many of the
obvious permission checks. We'll talk
about permission checks in a second.
Do I keep the markdown plans and issues
for later reference?
Okay.
This is a great question.
So,
let's say
that you uh have a great idea, you turn
it into a PRD,
raise and you then implement that PRD,
and the PRD is essentially done.
Raise your hand if you keep that
information in the repo, so you turn it
into a markdown file. Raise your hand if
you want to keep that around.
Cool. Okay. And raise your hand if you
if you don't want to keep it around. If
you want to get rid of it as soon as
possible. Yeah, this is I think an
a question that doesn't have a clear
answer.
What I'm really scared of
with any documentation decision is that
let's say that we have a PRD for this
gamification system, we keep it in the
repo.
We go on, go on, go on. Let's say a
month later, we want some edits to the
gamification system.
And we go in with Claude, and it finds
this old PRD and says, yes, I found the
original documentation for the PRD
system.
Well, it turns out that the actual code
has changed so much from the original
PRD that it's almost unrecognizable. The
names of things have changed, the um
file structure has changed, even the
requirements may have changed. We might
have actually tested it with users. This
is doc rot, where the documentation for
something is rotting away in your repo
and influencing Claude badly. Or Claude,
agents badly.
So, I tend to not keep it around. I tend
to get rid of it. And for me, because my
setup uses GitHub issues, I just mark it
as closed. It can fetch it if it wants
to, but it's got a visual indicator that
it's done. So, I tend to prefer
ditching these.
Thoughts on the BEADS framework from
Steve. Uh I've not tested it, but it
seems like sort of um another way to
manage Kanban boards and issues. Seems
uh very good, but I've not tried it.
Um
>> [clears throat]
>> Uh let me just quickly check the uh
setup here.
Let's take a couple of questions from
the room. Anybody got any questions at
this point about anything that we've
covered so far, especially this last
bit? Yes.
I thought it was
interesting your answer about like the
markdown files that you delete because
they
create like doc rot.
How about migrations? Like with
migration files, would you also squash
them after that?
Like database migrations? Yeah.
I don't know.
I hope that answers your question. I'm
so sorry. No, no. I think database
migrations are a different thing because
you have a sort of running record of
exactly what changed, and it's more
deterministic. And I think
Yeah, it's an interesting analogy. I'm
not sure. Let's talk about it
afterwards.
That's a good way of saying I've no
idea.
Yeah. Yeah. So, you mentioned that you
don't delete the PRD. You mentioned you
don't review the PRD once it's done.
Sorry, guys. Um I'm just trying to
listen to this guy's question. Have you
considered
uh using a deep think like ChatGPT or
something
to tell it, "Look at this PRD and tell
me if it
It takes about an hour.
Yeah, the question
The question here is um
should I um in the sort of early
planning stage be trying to optimize the
plan?
This is something I actually see a lot
of people doing, and it's a really good
um
idea. So, when you
Let's go back to the phases.
So, let's say that you have all of these
phases here.
And you
uh you get to the point where you've
sort of figured out everything with the
LLM, you understand where you're going,
you've created this sort of uh journey
destination documents here. How do you
then
uh
Like should you then try to optimize and
optimize and optimize that PRD until
it's the perfect PRD you can possibly
imagine?
I don't think there's a lot of value in
that.
Because I think the journey is really
just sort of a hint of where you want to
go, and the place that you need to be
putting the work is in QA.
And you can sort of do that AFK, I
suppose, but in my experience, you're
not going to get a lot of juice out of
it. Like it's the
The thing that really matters is getting
alignment with the AI, which is you do
in the grilling session initially.
Let's have one more question. Anyone got
any more? Yeah. How do you get in in
your workflow to get it to code the way
you want it to code it so by the time
you get to code review, it's at least
familiar, it uses the libraries you
wanted to use, Yeah. Um we had this
question before, actually, which was
like uh how do you uh enforce your
coding standards on the agents,
essentially? How do you get it to code
how you want it to code?
Now, there's essentially two different
ways of doing it.
Um you've got
I don't know. Come on. Push.
And you've got pull.
What do I mean mean by push and pull?
Um
Push is where you push instructions to
the LLM.
So, you say, okay, if you put something
in Claude.md,
uh talk like a pirate, that instruction
is always going to be sent to the agent,
right? So, that is a push, actually.
You're pushing tokens to it.
Pull is where you give the agent an
opportunity to pull more information.
And
that's for instance like skills. So, a
skill is something that can sit in the
repo, and it has a little description
header that says, okay, agent, you may
pull this when you want to.
My thinking, my current thinking about
code review and about coding standards
looks like this.
When you have an implementer,
What's going on? There we go.
Implementer.
I'm going to make this less red in a
second.
Um then
you want the coding standards to be
available via pull. If it has a
question, you want it to be able to sort
of answer it.
But if you then have an automated
reviewer afterwards, then you want it to
push. You want to push that information
to the reviewer. You want to say, "These
are our coding standards. Um make sure
that this code um follows them."
So if you have skills for instance, then
you want to push that stuff to the
reviewer so the reviewer has both the
code that's written and the coding
standards to compare to.
Hopefully that answers your question. I
can show you an automated version of
this as well actually.
Um
Yeah, let's do that now just while it's
fresh in my mind.
I recently um spent
uh
maybe a week or so
uh building this thing called
Sandcastle.
And Sandcastle is a
I was sort of unhappy with the options
out there for
um running agents AFK.
And what this does is it's essentially a
TypeScript library for running these
loops. So you have
uh a run function
that creates a work tree, um sandboxes
it in a Docker container,
and then allows you to run a prompt
inside that.
And in that work tree then, it's just a
Git branch and you have that code and
you can then merge it later.
If I open up
um
there are some really really nice ways
of viewing this and it essentially
allows you to run these kind of
automated loops and allows you to
parallelize across multiple different
agents really simply.
So I'll go into my Sandcastle file, go
into main.ts here.
And let's just walk through this.
So this is kind of like I showed you um
a sort of version of the Ralph loop
earlier. This is where we take it from
sequential into parallel.
We have here first of all a planner
that takes in it's has a plan prompt
here that looks at the backlog and
chooses a certain number of issues to
work on in parallel. Remember I showed
you that Kanban board where it had all
the blocking relationships? It works out
all the phases. So this one will say
okay, uh let's say we have
uh you can ignore all this glue code
here. This is essentially
just a set of issues, GitHub issues with
a title and with a a branch for you to
work on.
And then for each issue, we create a
sandbox
and then we run an implementer in that
passing in the issue number, issue
title, and the branch. This is like the
loop that we ran just before.
Then
if it created some commits, we then
review those commits.
This is essentially the loop.
What do we do with those commits?
We pass those into a
merger agent.
Which takes in a merge prompt, takes in
the branches that were created, takes in
the issues, and it just merges them in.
If there are any issues with the merge,
you know, with the types and tests and
that kind of thing, it solves them.
And this has been my uh flow for quite a
while now for working on most projects.
It works super super well. And uh yeah,
I recommend you check out Sandcastle if
you want to sort of learn more.
And to answer your question properly is
that in the reviewer
uh I would push the coding standards.
In the implementer, I would allow it to
pull.
And I'm actually using uh Sonnet for
implementation and Opus for um
reviewing cuz I consider reviewing sort
of I need I need the smarts then.
Any question Actually, let me uh before
we do more questions, let's go back
here.
Okay, where are we at?
Okay.
We sort of zooming everywhere in this uh
talk because I'm kind of having to run
things in parallel. So let's go back to
the improve code base architecture. It
has finally finished running and it's
found a bunch of architectural
improvement candidates.
So it's got essentially a cluster of
different modules that are all kind of
related that could probably be tested as
a unit.
Got number one, the quiz scoring
service. There's some reordering logic
extraction as well.
It has arguments for why they're coupled
and it has a dependency category as
well. So local substitutable in SQL
light within memory test DB.
Quiz scoring service just currently has
zero tests. This is the biggest gap. So
this is what it looks like when we come
back of
uh improve code base architecture.
Okay.
So
we have nominally kind of 17 minutes
left.
I don't know about you guys, but I'm
knackered.
>> [laughter]
>> Um I want to
>> [clears throat]
>> Let me let me kind of sum up for you.
Cuz I think we're sort of
reaching the end of our stamina. I'm
going to be available for the full time
if you want to um come and ask me
questions. Um I might do one more check
of the slide over, but let's kind of sum
up where we've got to.
So
this is essentially the flow.
Where throughout this whole process,
we're bearing in mind the shape of our
code base.
This is not a spec to code compiler.
This is not an AI that's sort of just
like churning out code. We are being
very intentional with the kind of
modules and the shape of the code base
that we want. We are making sure that we
are as aligned as possible by using the
grilling session, by really hammering
out our idea. We're not over indexing
into the PRD, we're not trying to read
every part of it. We're not thinking too
much about it even. We're then just
turning that into a set of
parallelizable issues which can be
worked on by agents in parallel.
We implement it
and we QA and code review the hell out
of it and then keep going back to that
implementation. One thing I didn't
really mention is that in the QA phase
what the QA phase is for is creating
more issues for that Kanban board.
So while it's implementing even, you can
be QAing the stuff and going back,
adding more issues. And the Kanban board
just allows you to add blocking issues
kind of um sort of infinitely really.
And then once that's all done, once
you've got code that you're happy with,
once you've got work that you're happy
with, then you can share it with your
team and you can get a full review.
So this is kind of like once you get
here, this is kind of one developer or
maybe a couple of developers sort of um
managing this and then it's kind of up
to you to figure out how to merge it
back in.
>> [sighs]
>> Of course
all of this can be customized by you.
This is just something that I have found
works. I'm not trying to like sell you
on a kind of approach here. What I
recommend if you take one thing away
from this session is that you should
head back, you should head to Amazon and
just buy a ton of those old books
because
I mean, I just found it so enlightening
reading them. Uh
you know,
pre-AI writing is always like a a really
fun to read anyway.
And
I just on every single page I found that
there was something useful and something
interesting to to read.
So thank you so much. Thank you for
putting up with the heat. Um hopefully
your body temperatures will reset soon.
Uh
thank you very much.
>> [applause]
[music]